si Monsieur Kern veut bien venir se
rasseoir
ouais bien Mesdames et Messieurs les
Ambassadeurs chers collègues Mesdames et
Messieurs les conseillers
je vous souhaite la bienvenue au Sénat
je suis très heureux de démarrer les
travaux de notre commission cette année
avec vous après avoir entendu tout à
l'heure votre collègue belge nous
exposer les priorités de ce semestre de
présidence tout particulier puisqu'il
clos un cycle européen et en prépare un
nouveau qui s'ouvrira après les
élections européennes de juin prochain
depuis le déclenchement de l'agression
russe en Ukraine il y a bientôt 2 ans et
plus encore depuis les décisions histori
des conseils européens de juin 2022 et
de décembre dernier l'Union européenne
se trouve à un tournant majeur de son
histoire où se profile un nouveau grand
élargissement 20 ans après celui de
2004 dans ce contexte géopolitique
nouveau pour l'Union et pour chacun de
ses États-membres il m'a paru
particulièrement utile de vous inviter
dans ce format collectif inédit à
éclairer notre propre réflexion sur les
enjeux de ce nouvel issement et sur les
réformes à préparer en conséquence pour
l'Union
européenne car je suis convaincu que
l'un ne va pas sans l'autre et les
échanges que nous venons d'avoir
avanthier à Namur dans le cadre de la
COSAC des présidents me renforc dans
cette conviction si nous si nous voulons
que l'entrée dans l'Union européenne de
nouveaux États-membres apporte plus de
puissance à l'Union comme à ses membres
il nous faut réformer l'Union et ses
politiques nous devons absolument éviter
qu'élargissement rime avec
affaiblissement l'élan vers
l'élargissement se nourrit de
considération géopolitique évidente dans
le contexte de la guerre en Ukraine mais
il ne peut selon moi ignorer la
nécessité en parallèle de mettre l'Union
en capacité d'intégrer de nouveaux
membres potentiellement jusqu'à 8 voire
10 avec la Géorgie désormais et un jour
peut-être le Kosovo puis-je rappeler ici
le constat du groupe des 12 experts
allemand qui ont planché sur ce sujet
notre commission a auditionné en
novembre dernier peu après la
déclaration de Grenade les deux
corapporteurs de ce groupe je les cite
l'Union européenne n'est pas encore
prête à accueillir de nouveaux membres
ni sur le plan institutionnel ni sur le
plan politique or l'Union européenne a
cependant fait un choix stratégique
définitif en ce sens selon le langage du
Conseil du 13 décembre dernier le
Conseil européen des 14 et 15 décembre
n'a pas omis dans ses conclusions de
compléter ce choix stratégique en
appelant l'Union euréenne aux réformes
nécessaires qu'elle- même doit mener
parallèlement aux réformes politiques
juridiques économique et social requise
pour les pays
candidats c'est le 4è critère de
Copenhague parfois passé sous silence
mais qui a autant d'importance que les
autres la capacité d'absorption de
l'Union européenne s'il revient au
gouvernement aux exécutifs et aux
institutions européennes de prendre leur
responsabilité à chacune des nombreuses
étapes qui jalonnent le processus
d'adhésion ce sera au peuple et au
Parlement qui les représentent en
dernier ressort aussi bien dans les
États-membres que dans les états
candidats de se prononcer sur l'entrée
de nouveaux États-membres dans l'Union
c'est dire la valeur que nous attachons
à notre dialogue d'aujourd'hui pour
tenter d'appréhender les positions et
sensibilités de chacun des États-membres
que vous représentez sur ces questions
majeures vos collègues ambassadeurs
d'Ukraine de Moldavie et de Géorgie à
Paris nous ont présenté le 30 novembre
dernier sous ce
format
séparément les efforts et les aspiration
de leurs pays
respectifs nous n'oublions pas bien sûr
les pays des Balcans occidentaux
auxquels nous sommes très attentif avec
notamment Martha Sidrac en particulier
qui est rapporteur avec claud Kerne et
Didier Marie sur l'élargissement et elle
est aussi présidente du groupe d'amitié
avec les pays de cette région à vous la
parole à présent représentant des États
membres de l'Union européenne pour nous
exposer brièvement votre vision celle de
vos capitales voir celle de vos peuples
sur ce défi majeur pour notre Europe qui
devrait être selon nous au premier plan
des thèmes de campagne pour les
prochaines élections européennes je le
clame depuis des mois
je rappelle que notre réunion fait
l'objet d'une captation
audiovisuelle vous connaissez la règle
du jeu elle vous a été préalablement
remise certes sévère mais vous verrez la
frustration qu'on les élus les
parlementaire de de ne s'exprimer que
alors vous avez beaucoup de chance parce
qu'on a dit entre 2 et 3 minutes nous
quelquefois à la COSAC notamment c'est
une minute voire 90 secondes et et dire
beaucoup de choses en en une minute mais
finalement vous savez je crois que en
restreignant ces temps on dit
l'essentiel vous disposez donc de 2
minutes ou tris pour un premier tour de
table cela doit permettre ensuite à nos
trois rapporteurs de vous interroger
tout aussi brièvement puis à l'assemblée
de nos collègues d'échanger avec vous
quant au tour de parole je vous prie de
pas en tenir rigueur si je passe outre
certaines questions protocolaires en
proposant de donner d'abord la parole
aux représentants des membres les plus
récents de l'Union européenne puis au
sein d'un groupe de de pays ayant
rejoint l'Union en même temps plutôt que
de suivre l'ordre alphabétique votre
collègue croate nous rejoindra ensuite
nous allons donc commencer par la
Bulgarie qui est entrée en 2007 puis
nous
pours est souffrante d'accord ah
d'accord on m'annonce que l'ambassadrice
de Roumanie est souffrante donc d'abord
bien sûr la parole à la Bulgarie
monsieur Émile Kazakov est devenu membre
de l'Union européenne
au 1er janvier 2007 et a présidé le
conseil dès le 1ier semestre en 2018
avec le slogan l'union fait la force
elle s'est rapidement intégrée à la
plupart des politiques européennes nous
connaissons l'attention particulière que
vous portez aux Balcans occidentaux et à
l'Ukraine donc Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
nous vous
écoutons merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames et Messieurs
sénateurs chers collègues euh je me
souviens très bien la date du 1er
janvier 2007 j'étais à Bruxelles à cette
époque en poste auprès de l'Union
européenne de de la mission bulgare
auprès de l'Union européenne donc 17
années se sont déjà écoulé de de ce
moment la Bulgarie n'est pas un membre
aussi récent que ça en fait euh mais
chronologiquement parlant et c'est c'est
exact nous avec la Roumanie et la croae
sont les derniers membres de l'Union
europ
donc je vais je voudrais commencer par
le notre attitude envers la
l'élargissement euh la Bulgarie en tant
qu'un pays faisant partie à la fois des
Balcans et de la région de de la mer
Noire soutient euh bien sûr le but
stratégique
euh de l'adhésion des pays de de des
Balcans occidentaux et des pays euh des
trois pays associés Ukraine Moldavie et
Georgie à l'Union européenne donc c'est
une nécessité stratégique qui est encore
plus bien exprimé dans le nouvelle dans
l'actuel contexte géopolitique qui est
déterminé par la guerre d'agression de
la Russie contre notamment contre
l'Ukraine en même temps nous soutenons
aussi la position que il faut aussi
regarder le principe des mérites propres
en évalu en évaluant le le progrès des
pays candidats envers leur
adhésion c'est aussi quelque chose qu'il
faut pas perdre de de notre attention
euh il a peut-être d'autres conditions
qui sont importantes de de
d'être prise en compte c'est bien sûr
l'alignement de ces pays candidats à la
pays à la pays à la excusez-moi aux
politiques commune de sécurité extérieur
et de sécurité euh aussi bien les
réformes dans le domaine des droits euh
fondamentaux euh les droits des
minorités nationales l'État de droit les
relations de bon voisinage donc voilà
sur le paquet élargissement
euh avant de de procéder à l'
élargissement nous attendons avec
beaucoup d'impatience le rapport de la
Commission
qui devrait être sorti pendant le
pendant le 2e trimestre de de cette
année sur l'impact l'analyse de la
Commission sur l'impact de
l'élergissement sur les politiques et
sur le budget de l'Union européenne euh
donc nous considérons aussi que il y a
beaucoup de choses considérer dans ce
contexte il y a des possibilités qui
déjà existe afin d'améliorer le la
décision de de prise de de décision de
de nuro européenne dans le cadre de
traité nous sommes sur la ferme
conviction que il serait
contreproductive à ce moment même de
rouvrir les traités euh ça serait
beaucoup plus opportun de de chercher
des possibilités de flexibilité dans le
cadre existant légal de l'Union
européenne il y a il y a plusieurs
possibilités il y a la possibilité de
l'abstention constructive il y a les
clauses passerelles il y a d'autres
possibilités euh et je vais je voudrais
finir par le fait que en fait nous nous
somms nous avons en face deux processus
de importance fondamentale le processus
d'élargissement et le processus de
d'approfondissement de deun européenne
euh la tâche de les mener de la de de
les mener à bien va déterminer le rôle
géopolitique de européenne dans les
décennies qui viennent merci beaucoup
merci merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur alors donc comme
l'ambassadrice de de Roumanie est
absente et que je vous ai donné les
raisons pour laquelle les chipriotes
aussi
euh alors on a les chipriotes qui sont
chez le président hein c'est ça ouis voà
et donc je vais donner tout de suite la
parole à Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de
Hongrie donc monsieur georgeabsbourg
laorine vous représenter ici non
seulement l'illustre famille qui marqua
profondément l'histoire de l'Europe mais
aussi le pays qui a rejoint l'Union
européenne en 2004 et vers lequel tous
les regards se tournent aujourd'hui
lorsque les chefs d'État au gouvernement
doivent à à l'unanimité s'entendre sur
l'élargissement notamment ou le soutien
de l'Ukraine en particulier donc merci
de nous faire part de nos points de vue
cher Monsieur l'Ambassadeur et bienvenue
à nouveau au Sénat merci beaucoup
monsieur le Président c'est un plaisir
d'être de nouveau au
Sénat je voudrais vous remercier
profondément pour votre initiative ainsi
ainsi que pour la possibilité d'aborder
ces questions stratégiques pour l'Europe
et pour la présidence hongroise du
conseil de ce juillet d'après notre
expérience certains des plus grands
conflits internationaux ont commencé
dans les Balcans il est donc très
important que nous soyons conscients de
l'histoire c'est la raison principale
pour laquelle la Hongrie a toujours
soutenu la politique
d'élargissement après l'agression russe
en Ukraine de nombreux États-membres
auparavant réticente ont compris que
l'élargissement était une nécessité
géopolitique surtout pour l'Ukraine
c'est bien sûr vrai mais cet aspect ne
concerne pas seulement l'Europe de l'Est
il nous paraissait évident depuis des
décennies que si l'Union européenne
s'abstenait d'intégrer les Balcans ces
pays se tourneraient vers d'autres
acteurs comme la Russie ou la
Chine par conséquent il est impératif
que l'intért des Balcans occidentaux à
rejoindre l'Union européenne soit
maintenue la présidence hongroise du
Conseil vise à accélérer le processus de
l'élargissement nous nous nous déjà
engageons à aider nos partenaires
également par nos experts en intégration
à remplir les critères nécessaires à
l'adhésion notre présidence vise à
organiser un sommet de la communauté
politique européenne et un sommet Union
européenne Balcans occidentau
cependant il est essentiel de maintenir
un équilibre entre les partenaires qui
travaillent depuis des années à
l'adhésion à l'Union européenne comme
les Balcans occidentaux et les
partenaires relativement nouveaux nos
voisins
orientaux nous pensons que lors des
processus d'adhésion le principe du
Mérite doit s'appliquer un cadre
d'institutionnalisation bien étalé doit
pouvoir veiller à ce à ce que ce
principe soit appliqué l'adhésion des
Balcans occidentaux est une affaire
inachevée depuis plus de 20 ans de ce
point de vue l'idée d'une intégration
progressive ne peut pas devenir une
alternative à
l'élargissement en ce qui concerne
l'Ukraine nous estimons que la décision
d'ouvrir les négociations était
prématuré étant donné que
l'élargissement est fondé sur le mérite
et juridiquement très structuré nous
attendons que Kief remplisse tous les
conditions nécessaires pour ouvrir les
négociations c'est pourquoi nous avons
trouvé une solution constructive lors du
dernier Conseil européen quand il était
devenu évident que l'Ukraine ne
parvenait pas à remplir tous les
conditions à ce stade selon le rapport
de la commission les conditions
suivantes n'ont pas encore été mise en
œuvre par Kiev l'Ukraine doit
renforoncer davantage la lutte contre la
corrup corruption l'Ukraine devrait
limiter l'influence excessive des
oligarches des oligarches dans la vie
économique politique et publique et le
gouvernement doit finaliser la réforme
du cadre juridique pour les minorités
nationales comme recommandé par la
Commission de Venise la Hongrie fera une
attention particulière à ce que
l'Ukraine garantisse pleinement les
droits des minorités nationales et
également mett en œuvre tous les
recommandations pertinentes de la
Commission de Venise de notre point de
vue il est indispensable que le droit de
la minorité hongroise en Ukraine soit
restaurer tels qu'ils étaient avant
2015 donc nous ne demandons pas des
mesures sans précédent mais un retour
aux droits déjà acquis avant 2015 nous
nous sommes prêts à aider l'Ukraine à
devenir capable de remplir ses
conditions quant à la réforme de l'Union
européenne avant de parler de tout
changement institutionnel nous devrons
examiner les effets sur les politiques
de l'Union européenne y compris le
budget l'agriculture le marché intérieur
et la cohésion néanmoins si nous parlons
des questions institutionnelles les
intérêts de chaque État membre devront
être respecté surtout dans ce domaine
stratégique je finisse tout de suite la
Hongrie préfère des solutions politiques
aux solutions procédurale parce que
c'est une condition fondamentale pour
l'égalité des États-membres euh
le maintien du consensus dans les
domaines stratégiques et donc essentiel
je reste avec ça àexercice n'est pas
facile vous voyez comment les
parlementaires souff j'ai essayé de
finir dans 3
minutes ou oui ce que je dis aussi toute
contribution écrite bien sûr nous
pourrons nous pourrons les intégrer à
notre travail je vais passer maintenant
la parole à Monsieur le Chef de Mission
adjoint monsieur Y kevis
petusco votre pays la Lettonie a
également rejoint l'Union européenne en
2004 avec les deux autres pays baltes et
il est aujourd'hui un ardent défenseur
de l'élargissement et de l'aide à
l'Ukraine en particulier donc quel est
le point de vue depuis Riga et je
demanderai à Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de
de Lituanie de se préparer pour la
suite euh merci madames et Messieurs le
sénateur c'est vraiment plaisir et grand
honneur pour moi d'être ici mon
ambassadeur est toujours euh aujourd'hui
à Grenoble c'est pourquoi il ne pouvit
pas venir euh donc s'il s'agit de de nos
sujets de sujet de de la discussion bon
euh cette année c'est le 20e
anniversaire que la lonie est euh est
devenu le pays membre euh de de l'Union
européenne mais en fait le processus
très important est commencé en fait
avant avec l'accession les négociations
sur l'accession de l'onie dans cette euh
dans l'Union européenne c'est il
s'appelle
européanisation européanisation de pays
c'est unentrès un trè euh processus un
très compliqué un peu mais aussi très
motivant de devenir de de euh renforcer
le la défense de valeur de nos valeurs
communes c'est pourquoi donc bien sûr
que on soutient le élargissement de
l'Union européenne
euh euh et maintenant
notre notre point de vue c'est que bien
sûr que il faut que l'Union européenne
s'adapte à cette à cette euh nouvelle
situation avec le pays membre peut-être
35 par exemple mais on voit qu'on peut
s'adapter en même temps avec les euh
avec C processus de l'accession et s'il
s'agit de de changement de traité
possible donc là je suis d'accord avec
euh Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de Bulgarie
qu'en fait pour l'instant peut-être ça
sera pas euh tout à fait productif de
commencer les négociations très très
très compliquées
euh parce que on on voit qu'il y a des
possibilités dans le traité actuel qu'on
peut utiliser euh je sais pas s'il
s'agit de de votes euh la la close
passerelle par exemple donc en fait
c'est en bref la position leonne merci
beaucoupurur pardon merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur donc je vais passer
maintenant la parole à Monsieur
l'ambassadeur de la République de
Lituanie monsieur Alexis Junas euh votre
pays a fait de l'élargissement une
priorité politique géopolitique et de
sécurité majeure on l'a encore entendu à
la COSAC de la part de mon ami rad
Villet qui est notre homologue euh au
Parlement au Parlement lituanien euh
donc voilà confirmez-nous ce point de
vue que nous avons souvent entendu mais
en tout cas je merci monsieur le
Président et Mesdames et Messieurs
sénateurs c'est un grand plaisir pour
commencer l'année avec M vieux pour
cette année mais aussi avec la
discussion sur l'Europe sur
l'regissement euh brièvement parce que
c'était déjà beaucoup de choses ont été
fait déjà discuté exprimé par mes
collègues mais trois points peut-être le
premier point de notre côté pour nous
l'argissement c'est un possibilité
vraiment c'est une possibilité pour
renforcer l'Europe pour avoir l'Europe
plus large pour avoir cette peut-être
parti géopolitique élément géopolitique
très très important dans cette contexte
géopolitique très compliqué pour nous
c'est une opportunité possibilité
aussiism c'est une possibilité pour
réformer l'Union Européen parce que j'ai
passé 8 années à Bruxelle je sais très
bien que c'est juste après la crise
après le pression l'Europe devient plus
fort l'Europe fait le réformes
nécessairire c'est pas que dans la
période tranquille que l'Europe bouge et
pour moi cette cet élergissement cette
défi devient possibilité pour l'Europe
se réformer et aussi c'est une
possibilité pour réformer les les les
les pays candidats parce que c'est c'est
une vraiment possibilité pour
reconstruire l'Ukraine européen pour
reconstruire l'Ukraine dans la nouvelle
méthode et c'est une vraiment opportuné
pour faire la impact de de l'Union
européenne dans notre voisinage
deuxèement je pense que la lonie
peut-être c'est une la meilleur preu de
des réussite de politique de lgissement
comme nous aimons beaucoup les chiffres
je je voudrais juste partager peut-être
quelques chiffres j'ai regardé les
derniè sondage de Eurobaromètre sur sur
l'opinion public en ce qui concerne
l'Europe pour moi c'est une des chiffres
très importants c'est la confiance euh
dans l'Union européenne et les sondages
donnent les résultats que 63 % litonens
sont ont la confiance dans l'Union
Européen c'est la 3è place dans l'Union
Européen après denemark après Suède et
pour moi c'est une explication pourquoi
les Lituaniens sont vraiment si engagés
pour pour l'argissement parce qu'il a
soutien pour notre peuple nos citoyens
pour pour cette politique deuxème
chiffre très important euh quels sont
les pays le plus optimistes ce que con
l'avenir de l'Europe et c'est aussi la
lonie entre les premières c'est 76 %
lonens sont optimistes en ce qui
concerne l'avenir de l'Europe et je
pense ça aussi très un chiffre très très
important et peut-être le dernier
chiffre pour vous transformation
économique j'ai regardé une peut-être
élément très important c'est pb par
habitant quelle était pb par habitant de
Lanie 2004 et c'était 46 6 % de moyen
européen et quel est pb par habitant
maintenant c'est c'est 90 % donc nous
avons fait pendant les 20 dernières
années un progret économique incroyable
et je pense c'est aussi une preuve que
la politique de légissement pour nous
donner cette cadre des réformes cette
motivation pour réformer notre pays donc
quand on parle sur la politique
degissement je pense il faut d'être plus
optimiste il faut aussi avoir plus de
confiance sur are capacité pour trouver
la solution nécessaire pour réformer
l'Union européenne comme j'ai passé 8
années dans dans les discussions à
Bruxelles j'étais le premier
représentant de ltonie dans le groupe de
travail degissement 2004 et je souviens
je je connais très bien qu'il a déjà
beaucoup desutiles pour faire les
conséquences de l'gissement acceptable
il a beaucoup beaucoup de possibilité je
sais pas période transitoire optout il y
a des exceptions donc c'est vraiment il
a des outils que l'Europe peut utiliser
pour vraiment faire les conséquences
acceptables pour pour nous donc d'être
plus optimiste et avoir plus de
confiance et donc si j'ai bien compris
pas pas de transformation des
traités dans dans le visage les traité
don beaucoup de possibilités c'est pas
que on a utilisé déjà tous les
potentialités ne faisait que confirmer
votre pensée je vais passer la parole
maintenant à Monsieur Claude Bonello de
de Malte vous êtes représentant adjoint
de la République de Malte à Paris le
chemin vers l'adhésion de votre pays ne
fut pas un long fleuve tranquille
puisque il mit 17 ans à être parcouru
donc quelle est aujourd'hui la vision
maltaise de l'élargissement avec
rappelons-le quand même une présidente
du Parlement européen qui est maltaise
encore euh
oui monsieur le Président disting invité
chers collègues merci beaucoup tout
d'abord euh pour nous donner l'occasion
euh de d'échanger nos points de vue sur
ce sujet très important euh en effet
comme mes collègues ont déjà dit en
cette période critique pour l'avenir de
l'Union européenne euh l'élargement est
en sujet important insensible euh
sucessible de façonner les trajectoires
de l'Union pour les décennies à venir
euh Malte aussi soutient un processus de
l'allugement fondé sur le sur la mérite
continue à soutenir tous les partenair
dans le parcours vers l'adhésion nous
voulons que l' lgement reste
crédible prévisible et fermement encré
dans le
méthodologie révisé en mainant l'accent
sur les réformes fondamentales en
intégrant la princip la principe de
réversibilité eu l'ajustement concerne
les citoyens l'avenir des générations
futures
de des généraisations futur et de
l'avenir de de l'Europe eu euh a ce
concerne le processus de réflexion sur
les réformes internes de l'Union
européenne ce processur et le processus
deement doit suivre deux voies
distinctes mais parallèles comme mes
autres collègues ont déjà dit aussi euh
nous attendons avec grand intérêt aussi
une réflexion objective et réaliste qui
poserait les bases d'une éventuel
processus qui sétiendra à qui c'est
vraiment nécessaire ceci est d'autant
plus important qu'il semble y avoir une
idéeour le fait que les trait actuell
sont à l'épreuve de de l'ajissement euh
nous devons veiller aussi à ne pas inter
les discussions sur les réformes avec
des solutions ou des échantes préconçu à
cet égard nous attendons avec impatience
la contribution de la Commission
européenne aussi euh nous notre position
est bien con nue nous ne sommes pas
favorable au lancement des discussions
institutionnelles qui ne cessent de
diviser et qui ne risque euh de ne pas
abourtir et nous ne vons pas de de
discussion précipité euh pour nous la
priorité absolue est de veilleur à ce
qui concerne notre unité notre cohésion
et notre représentativité reste constant
merci merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
vais passer maintenant à la Pologne avec
Monsieur vislav Tarka qui est chef de
mission adjoindre l'ambassade de de
Pologne pays auquel nous lit des liens
anciens très étroit est très fort pays
moteur pour l'élargissement et la
sécurité de l'Union européenne qui vient
de connaître un changement politique
important quel sens dans sa double
acceptation de direction et de
signification les autorités polonaises
entendent aujourd'hui donner à la
politique d'élargissement de l'Union
européenne c'est à
vous monsieur le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Sénateurs merci pour pour
nous accueillir ici euh Pologne nous
apprécions la décision prise par le
Conseil européen de lancer les
négociations d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie cette décision doit être
mise en œuvre en screening devrait être
organisé dans les semaines à venir nous
attendons de la commission qu'elle
fournisse bientôt aux États-membres en
projet de cadre de négociation les
négociations d'adhésion seront complexes
et difficiles dans de nom dans de
nombreux domaines notamment économique
les deux partis doivent être bien
préparés afin de assurer que l'élan
n'est pas perdu lorsque le pourparleur
entre dans le détail le perspective
d'adhésion à l'Union européennes sont
importantes pour l'oukraine mais le pays
doit survivre à la guerre et nous devons
donc prendre une décision sur l'aide
financière les autorités ukrainiennes
préparent en plan pour l'oukraine la
reconstruction devrait être liée au
processus d'adhésion à l'Union
européenne toute considération
éventuelle sur les réformes interne de
l'Union européenne devrait faciliter le
processus d'élargissement et non
l'interdire ou le retarder et sur le
balcan nous comprenons que les États des
Balcans s'enquièent d'être laissés pour
compte dans le processus d'intégration
de l'Union européenne une fois que
l'ouraine et la Moldavie ont posé avec
succès leur candidature à l'adhésion à
l'Union européenne nous voulons les
assurer qu'il n'y a pas de concurrence
en le entre le pays cand
le pays des Balcans occidentaux rêvit
une importance stratégique pour la
Pologne toute comme pour l'ensemble de
l'Union européenne nos objectifs sont
clairs et découlent de l'agenda de
Thessalonique la Pologne soutient sans
équivoque l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne car nous savons que la
perspective européenne est en
catalysateur des réformes
transformatrice l'une des conditions du
processus d'élargissement de l'Union
européenne reste l'alignement de
politiques étrangères de pays candidat
sur la politique étrangère et des
sécurités commune de l'Union européenne
la stabilisation durable de la région
des Balcans occidentaux est cruciale
pour la sécurité de l'ensemble de la
zone euroatlantique nous passensons donc
euh euh qu'il est nécessaire de
manifester la présence et l'intérêt
constant de l'OTAN dans la région nous
sommes favorables à la poursuite de
l'intégration de la région dans
l'alliance sur la base du modèle
privilégié par nos partenaires qu'il
s'agisse des aspirations bosniaques à
l'adhésion ou du partenariat avec la
Serbie des utiles hybrides amplifiés par
la puissance des technologies modernes
et des médias sociaux sont utilisés par
des acteurs agressifs dont la Russie et
la Chine pour accroître la polarisation
politique et remmettre en cause la
cohésion institutionnelle d'État
indépendant la manipulation des
d'information par par des acteurs
étrangers peut peut nuire aux priorités
de notre politique étrangère et de
sécurité dans la région des Balcans
occidentaux il est donc nécessaire de
soutenir le journalisme indépendant et
encourager l'éducation aux médias dans
la région en outre une double approche
est nécessaire promouvoir une
information non fausé d'une part et
soutenir le stratcom National et le
renforcement des
capacité dans la région d'autre part
merci merci beaucoup je vais maintenant
laisser la parole à Monsieur
Yan qui est ambassadeur de la République
slovaque à Paris nouvel ambassadeur
m't-il dit votre pays a connu une
amélioration importante de son niveau de
vie de sa croissance économique et de sa
stabilité depuis 20 ans qu'il a rejoint
l'Union européenne votre pays est aussi
une force de proposition en matière
d'élargissement et de réforme de l'Union
européenne nous sommes ravis de vous
entendre Monsieur l'Ambassadeur merci
monsieur le Président Mesdames les
sénatrices monsieur les sénateur chers
collègues tout d'abord je voudrais vous
remercier pour cette
initiative très intéressante agréable je
suis d'accord avec ceux qui disent que
l'élargissement et la réforme de l'Union
européenne sont vraiment les défis
principaux pour nous tous pour les
années à
venir le monde aussi que la
géopolitique sont en train de changer
radicalement et nous devons y réagir
l'gissement et le renforcement de
l'Union européenne doit faire partie de
ce processus même si ce n'est pas
facile cependant le cours de l'Histoire
dépend des actions des gens de notre
activité il n'est pas
prédestiné c'est ce que nous nous devons
nous rappel sans cesse si nous voulons
avoir une Europe stable forte unie et
coopérative cela ne sera pas possible
sans les pays des Balcans occidentaux et
les pays de l'Europe de
l'Est si nous investissons pas d'effort
et de ressources dans ces pays nous
perdrons complètement la confiance de
leur peuple et l'espace géopolitique
sera occupé par autre puissance cela ne
signifiera pas la paix et la prospérité
pour notre Europe la Slovaquie a
toujours soutenu la politique de de
gissement de l'Union européenne et nous
apprécions les progrès de ces derniers
mois dans ce
domaine-elà nous sommes bien sûr lucide
en ce qui concerne la nécessité pour
l'Union mais aussi pour les pays
candidats de bien se préparer à la
perspective d'adhésion y compris mener
des réformes
nécessaires nous sommes convaincus que
le processus de lgissement doit être
fondé sur mérite les pays candidats adér
ran dès qu'il soi prêt il est important
aussi selon nous que l'Union européenne
maintienne une approche symétrique et
équilibrée envers les de deux régions le
sud-est ça veut dire Balcans occidentaux
et l'Est trè des pays ouukraine Moldavie
et Georgie c'est essentiel en terme de
crédibilité de la politique de
largissement de
l'Union le concept d'intégration
progressive ou adhésion graduelle de
nouveaux pays membres à l'Union à le
potentiel de préparer au mieux les pays
candidats à leur future adhésion en les
engageant dans une coopération aussi
étroite que possible avec l'Union
européenne avant leur entrée dans
l'Union de de sur croix il rend tangible
leur perspective européenne ce qui
constitue la meilleure motivation pour
les effort des réformes mesdames
Messieurs le processus de l'gissement le
processus de réforme devait aller au paè
de ne pas se conditionner l'un l'autre
l'Union doit être
prête élargissement le plus tôt possible
et pour conclure je voudrais souligner
que tout effort visant à rationaliser le
processus décisionnel de l'Union doit
garantir qu'aucun État membre ne perd sa
voix voir vote la Slovaquie voit une
marche de flexibilité dans le cadre
actuel des traités pour procéder à ces
ajustements pour l'instant nous ne
pensons pas qu'il soit nécessaire de
consacrer du temps et de l'énergie à la
discussion sur l'ouverture des traités
européens
merci merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
madame metkaay Pavic bienvenue à nouveau
au Sénat madame l'ambassadrice de
Slovénie qui s'est engagé fortement pour
l'élargissement en priorité au Balcans
Occident dans tout comment
appréciez-vous le plan d'investissement
et de croissance qui est annoncé qui a
été annoncé le mois dernier en faveur de
des pays de la région y voyez-vous
justement une occasion d'avancer vers
l'objectif que vous appelez de vos
vœux euh merci monsieur le Président et
merci pour cette initiative
euh bonjour à tout euh et tout la
sénatrice sénateur ici présente et mes
collègues
euh comme plusieurs de mes collègues ont
déjà dit à la lumière de nouveaux défis
géostratégiqu de nouveaux élargissement
sont devenus la priorité et la
N et la nécessité de l'Union européenne
la Slovénie est convaincue que nous
devrons saisir ces ces moments politique
pour construire une Europe plus forte et
plus unie d'ici à la fin de la décennie
euh je dois mentionner que pour nous il
est important de faire une effort plus
équilibre pour ne pas laisser le balcan
Occident temps derrière en particulier
la
bosnieherzégovine concrètement il est
clé de prendre une décision sur
l'ouverture de négociation de que
possible au plus tard en mars 2 cette
année notre objectif est de rendre le
processus d'adhésion de la
Bosnie-Herzégovine irréversible ce qui
est particulièrement important dans l'
environnement international actuel que
mes collègues sont déjà mentionnés nous
soutenons la proposition du président du
Conseil européen d'un calendrier précis
à savoir 2030 ça don euh donnera au pays
candidat une ligne directrice clair et
une inicitation à accélérer leur
réformes et à nous aux États-membres
c'est là don le temps de se préparer
c'est-à-dire préparer les réformes
internes nécessaires et nous nous
attendons avec impatience la
communication euh sur le euh sur les
réformes annoncé par la Commission
européenne nous espérons que les
dirigeant adoptent une accord sur
roadmap pour les réformes internes d'ici
l'été 2024 dans tous les cas la réforme
interne devrait se dérouler
parallèlement au processus
d'élargissement en particulier nous
pensons que le futur élargissement ne
devrait pas attendre une réforme
institutionnelle global et si je me
réfère à modification de traité
fondateur il est clair que élargissement
et l'approfondissement dans inter
domomaines politique devront être
conclus en même temps par exemple tel
que marché unique la transition verte ou
la transformation technologique et
digitale nous sommes conscientes que une
élargissement majeur aura aurait de
conséquences importantes sur certaines
politiques et leur budget en particulier
sur la politique agricole commune et la
cohésion et nous sommes prêt de
travailler sur cette question euh sur
laeicace de l'Union européenne si nous
voulons que l'Union européenne soit plus
efficace en tant que acteur mondial nous
devons parler de changement dans notre
processus de décision en particulier
dans le domaine de politique étrangère
et de sécurité commune la Slovénie a
rejoint la groupe d'amis sur la voau de
la à la majorité qualifié dans le cadre
de pesque et nous sommes très actifs
dans explorations de différents options
qui donnent aux pays membres le garant
nécessaire et qui figure déjà dans les
traités existant et mon dernier point
c'est pour nous c'est l'état de droit
est extrêmement important c'est la base
de fonctionnement de l'Union européenne
les mécanismes de conditionnalité liés à
l'état de droit devront être renforcés
pour le futur élargissement merci merci
Madame l'ambassadrice je vais passer
maintenant la parole à Monsieur Thomas
schrobac premier secrétaire de
l'ambassade de République Tchèque vous
êtes un expert reconnu des questions
euré pouvezv nous partager point de
vue sur depuis Prague mais depuis
Paris merci monsieur le
Président ch sénatrices chers sénateurs
chers collègu merci de cette
occasion je ne suis pas ici en tant que
spécialiste je suis ici en tant que la
PAL copie de mon ambassadeur monsieur
flman qui est
malheureusement un empêchement médical
il ne peut pas participer à cet
événement euh j'aimerais dire en
quelques mots la position tchèque en ce
qui concerne l'élargissement alors la
République tchèque soutenait toujours
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne
pendant les
années malgré les gouvernements
successifs c'était toujours la priorité
de la République tchèque et nous sommes
très heureux que l'année dernière
euh au Conseil européen de juin de
décembre
euh l'Union européenne a pris ses
décisions historiques de
lancer les débats d'adhésion avec
l'Ukraine la Moldavie et nous ne voulons
pas laisser de côté aussi les Balcans
occidentaux parce que les Balcans
occidentaux c'était toujours la priorité
de la présidence tchèque avec nos amis
français nos amis
suédois on a on a
lancé le dialogue d'adhésion avec avec
l'Albanie la Macédoine du Nord on on a
réussi à donner pendant la présidence
tchèque le statut du candidat la
bosniazgovine
et on a fait le premier pas vers la
suppression des visas avec le Kosovo
alors nous sommes conscient que le les
Balcans occidentaux ne doivent pas
rester une tâche blanche sur la la car
d'Europe mais pour les raisons
sécuritaires et stratégiques il doivent
être partie intégrante de notre de notre
continent ce qui est très important
c'est de préserver l'unité de l'Union
vis-à-vis de l'agression russe en
Ukraine là l'Ukraine doit avoir notre
plan soutien parce que elle paye de son
sang et défend son son indépendance et
son intégrité alors nous devons euh nous
devons euh la soutenir par tous les par
tous les moyens possi à ce qui
concerne l'avenir de l'Union européenne
alors mon pays n'est pas partisan de la
révision des traités
d'adhésion de de traités des traités
fondamental maintenant
mais nous devons chercher plutôt les
moyens
comment élarg comment élargir les
compétences de l'Union dans le cadre
juridique actuel alors
c'est grosso modo les grand de ligne de
la de la position tchèque en vis-à-vis
de l'élargissement
merci merci bien don la parole à votre
voisin Monsieur l'Ambassadeur de Suède
can kesson où j'uris de me rendre
prochainement pour la pour accompagner
le président de la République en visite
d'État c'est à la fin du mois c'est une
visite qui a été remise suite aux
événements qui s'étaient produit nous
sommes très curieux de vous entendre sur
la ligne de la Suède en matière
d'élargissement et et de réforme votre
pays étant très engagé en faveur de la
paix et de la sécurité et qui sort
presque d'une d'une présidence du
Conseil de l'Union
européenne merci monsieur le Président
mesames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs chers
collègues merci tout d'abord à la
commission des affaires européennes pour
cette invitation et cette opportunité de
discuter de deux sujets absolument
fondamental essentiels pour l'avenir de
de l'Europe tout d'abord l'élargissement
de l'UE est dans l'intérêt de la Suède
et de de l'Union bien entendu c'est l'un
des instruments les plus stratégiques de
lieu pour renforcer la sécurité la St et
la prospérité de de l'Union et nous
avons un intérêt tout particulier à
soutenir le rapprochement de l'Ukraine
avec
l'UE donc nous nous félicitons de la
décision lors du dernier Conseil
européen d'ouvrir des négociation
d'adhésion avec ce pays il est en même
temps et cela a déjà été mentionné par
mes collègues très important
d'encourager les autres pays candidats
de continuer leurs réformes pour devenir
membres
le processus d'élargissement doit être
basé sur mérite nous sommes en même
temps prêt à considérer les propositions
relatives à une approche graduelle
encore une fois pour encourager les
réformes dans les pays concernés la
Suède ne pense pas qu'il soit nécessaire
de modifier le traité pour faire face à
l'élarchissement néanmoins mon pays est
en faveur du vote à la majorité
qualifiée
dans certains domaines pour garantir
l'efficacité d'une Union élargie cela
pourrait se faire par exemple dans des
cas précis en ce qui concerne la
politique étrangère commune relative au
droits de l'homme aux sanctions et aux
opérations
civiles en ce qui concerne la
composition de la commission nous
souhaitons conserver un commissaire par
pays ce principe est essentiel pour la
légitimité et la transparence de la
commission ainsi que pour l'influence de
tous les états- membres quel que soit la
taille du
pays pour ce qui est de l'orientation
politique de l'UE de manière plus
générale la Suède est favorable à une
concentration du travail législatif dans
les domaines qui apportent une valeur
ajoutée évidente et comme toujours bien
entendu sur la base des principes de
subsidiarité et de
proportionnalité finalement une
observation peut-être assez évidente
nous avons pu constater que lorsque les
crises frappent les citoyens se tournent
vers l'Europe depuis la guerre en
Ukraine le soutien non seulement à
l'adhésion de la Suède à l'OTAN à
basculé comme vous le savez mais ceci le
soutien des Suédois à lieu qui n'a
jamais été si fort 54 % en ont
aujourd'hui une opinion positive ou même
très positive ce qui fait que les
Suédois se retrouent aujourd'hui parmi
les européens les plus positifes envers
l'Union je m'arrête là
merci merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je
passe tout de suite la parole à Monsieur
vol volfgand
Wagner en 1995 votre pays l'Autriche a
rejoint l'Union européenne les
responsables Autrichiens que nous
rencontrons souvent et qui au fil du
temps deviennent des des amis sont
unanimes à soutenir l'élargissement en
particulier aux Balcans occidentaux mais
CIT des réformes préalables ou
parallèles du fonctionnement interne de
l'Union européenne c'est à
vous merci monsieur le Président euh
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs euh
chers collègues euh je voudrais
commencer déjà
avec une expression que vous vous avez
déjà mentionné que pour nous pour
l'Autriche c'est surtout les les pays
des Balcans occidentaux qui qui sont les
premiers qui sont devenus des des des
candidats alors il est impératif de de
notre point de vue que les pays
candidates des Balcans occidentaux ne
derrière en comparaison avec les nouvels
candidats comme l'Ukraine la Moldavie
ainsi que la Géorgie eu ces pays ont
grâce au traité d'association déjà un un
niveau d'indégration plus élevé que les
pays des des Balcans occidentaux et euh
du point de vue de notre gouvernement il
est impératif de d'assurer une situation
équitable level playing field comme le
dit notre ministre des Affaires
étrangères et euh
et l'élchissement au Balcans occidentaux
n'a pas qu'une importance théorique
notre intérêt pour l'Europe du Sud-Est à
des raisons très concrètes d'abord nous
avons vu déjà plusieurs fois dans notre
histoire les conséquences d'une
instabilité de dans notre voisinage le
plus récemment au moment de la
dissolution de de la Yougoslavie dans
les années 90 deuxièmement nos liens
avec les pays des Balcans sont très
forts à l'Union européenne dans sa
totalité au premier rang des échanges
commerciaux avec les Balcans occidentaux
de loin et l'Autriche elle-même avec ses
entreprises et un des premiers
investisseurs dans tous ces pays dans
tous les pays de de des Balcans
occidentaux c'est-à-dire qu'il n'est pas
tout à fait correct qu' nous disant que
l'Union européenne va s'élagir en fait
l'Union européenne est déjà là euh
l'élargissement de l'Union européenne ça
veut dire transférer nos règles et nos
valeurs chez nos partenaire et ça c'est
vraiment une nécessité pour le l'avenir
du point de vue autrichien il serait fau
de considérer l'élarchissement comme un
processus purement technique ça fait
déjà plus de 20 ans comme c'était déjà
mentionné avant par mes collègues que
nous promettant à ces pays une
perspective d'ataison ataision et aucune
date concrète n'est n'est pas pas encore
en vue d'un point de vue géostratégique
nous risquons ainsi de perdre les
peuples de ces pays au profit d'autres
grandes puissances le gouvernement
autrichien défend donc l'idée de prendre
des dès maintenant des mesures concrètes
d'intégration même si une adésion
complète n'est pas encore faisable euh
notre ministre des Affaires étrangères a
proposé pour cela un concept
d'intégration graduelle qui était déjà
mentionné par plusieurs collègues et
c'est clair et évident comme la dit
aussi mon collègue hongrois que ça ne
remplace remplace euh bien sûr pas la
une intégration une adhésion mais c'est
la première étape accélérée pour une
adhésion
éventuelle euh nous pouvons d'ors et
déjà intégrer davantage les pays sans
pour autant devoir modifier les traités
tout n'est pas noir et blanc l'adtision
de plein droit de tous les pays
candidates restent le but mais d'ici là
pourquoi ne pas approfondir la
coopéation dans des des domaines où cela
apporte des bénéfices mutuels le
contexte géopolitique que vous
connaissez tous nous a fait per à
prendre à conscience que les pays qui
partagent notre mode de vie et nos
valeurs constituent une minorité dans le
monde il est d'autant plus important de
construire et de cultiver des
partenariats et alliances stables et
durables en commençant dans notre plus
proche voisinage merci de votre
attention merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
je vais passer maintenant la parole à
notre
ambassadeur grec monsieur
dimitrioselakis la Grèce qui a accueilli
le fameux Conseil européen de
tessalonique en juin 2003 qui a lancé et
structuré la perspective européenne des
Balcans occidentaux la promesse de
Thessalonique quel est aujourd'hui son
engagement en faveur de l'élargissement
et des réformes qui permettront enfin de
voir cette promesse
tenue merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames les sénatrices messieurs les
sénateurs chers collègues merci beaucoup
pour cette opportunité de la réunion de
présenter nos nos idées donc vous avez
mentionné monsieur le Président les
Balcans donc comme vous l'avez suggéré
la Grèce a toujours été à l'avant-garde
des efforts visant à l'intégration
européenne des Balcans occidentaux nous
pensons que leur adhésion à l'Union
profitera aux deux partis nous appelons
à l'accélération de la perspective
européenne dans les Balcans occidentaux
notamment en faisant progresser la mise
en œuvre d'une intégration progressive
fondée sur le mérite et réversible sur
la voie de l'adhésion à
partentière aussi en ce qui concerne euh
les récentes décisions du Conseil
européen nous sommes très satisfaits de
la décision prise d'ouvrir les
négociations d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine
et la Moldavie ainsi que d'accorder le
statut de candidat à la geéorgie nous
encourageons l'Ukraine la Moldavie et la
geéorgie à poursuivre et accélérer les
réformes nécessaires notamment dans les
domaines de l'État de droit et de la
lutte contre la corruption et le crime
organisé en ce qui concerne donc
l'élargissement en général et les
institutions la Grèce soutient
l'intégration progressive des pays
candidat à condition que la crédibilité
du processus d'élargissement et des
conditions de concurrence équitable
entre ce pays soit
garanti nous pensons qu'il ne faut pas
retarder davantage l'élargissement sous
prétexte de la N d'un approfondissement
institutionnel nous défendons aussi la
nécessité que tous les pays candidats
soient traités selon les mêmes règles et
les priorités géopolitiques ne doivent
pas bouleverser un processus fondé sur
le mérite qui est strictement
défini la réflexion sur les réformes
institutionnelles est toujours la
bienvenue pour des améliorations en
temps voulu sans que celle-ci soit conçu
comme condition préalable à
l'élargissement nous sommes fermement
convaincu que le cadre institutionnel
actuel de l'Union européenne est adapté
à
l'élargissement quelques ajustements
nécessaire par exemple la pondération
des voies Conseil pourrait être examinée
à la fin du processus
d'adhésion concernant spécifiquement la
question de la capacité déditionnelle du
Conseil le passage au vote à la majorité
qualifiée ne devrait pas être posé comme
une condition de
l'élargissement la Grèce est fermement
convaincu que tout usage abusif
de l'unanimité ne devrait pas conduire à
modifier les règles qui garantissent le
respect des intérêts nationaux
vitaux nous devrions plutôt nous
concentrer à développer davantage une
culture de consensus en accordant une
attention particulière aux nouveaux
arrivants cette culture doit également
être considérée comme l'un de nos
principes fondamentaux qui doivent être
intégrés dans le processus
d'élargissement le passage au vote à la
majorité qualifié pour les décisions
dans le domaine de la la politique
européenne de sécurité commune et de
défense commune pourrait Sapper l'unité
entre les États-membres et par
conséquent la capacité de l'Union à
fonctionner comme un acteur cohérent
fort et fiable au niveau mondial et
finalement concernant le futur réformes
internes nous pensons que nous devrions
nous concentrer sur l'ajustement des
politiques et du financement de l'Union
européenne qui ont une incidence directe
sur la vie quotidienne des citoyens de
l'Union européenne et façonn donc la
perception du public à l'égard de
l'élargissement je vous remercie
monsieur le Président merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur monsieur ravier Blanco qui
est conseiller à l'ambassade d'Espagne
votre pays eu la charge d'un semestre
européen particulièrement chargé et
décisif en matière d'élargissement
second de 2023 j'ai rappelé les termes
très importants pour nous la déclaration
de Grenade insistant sur les réformes
parallèles à mener nous savons que la
présidence implique un fort engagement
mais aussi une certaine neutralité
peut-être peut-être que le moment est
venu pour vous de vous en départir pour
expliciter la position propre de
l'Espagne
merci merci monsieur le Président Madame
les sénatrices monsieurs les sénateurs
che ambassadeurs et collègues c'est
toujours un plaisir et un privilège de
comparître dans cette chambre pour
aborder un sujet si important et
complexe comme l'égement et les réformes
nécessaires que l' doit mener
parallèlement l'Espagne est un pays
traditionnellement favorable à
l'élargissement à la fois en raison de
sa propre expérience des transformations
politiques et économique et en raison de
sa compréension des besoins politiques
et historiques de l'UE et des pays
candidats en outre l'Espagne est l'un
des pays dans lesquels l'élargissement
bénéfice du plus grand soutien citoyen
près des 75 %. cet engagement en faveur
de l'élargissement s'est manifesté au
cours de notre présidence que vous venez
de le dire monsieur le Président qui a
commencé par une visite du président
Sanchez à Kiev et s terminé par les
conclusions du Conseil européen dans
lesquelles l'ouverture des négociations
avec l'Ukraine et la Moldavie a été
convenu ce qui représente un soutien
politique important pour ces deux pays
dans les contextes difficiles de
l'agression rousse en Ukraine cette
position est s'est réflétée aussi lors
de la réunion informelle des ministres
des Affaires étrangères àoursy et du
Conseil européen informel des Grenad qui
dans la déclaration finale a défini
l'élargissement comme un investissement
géostratégique de l'UE qui contribuera
au renforcement de notre continent il
convient toutefois d'aborder ces
dossiers avec prudence en prêtant
attention à l'impact de l'élargissement
sur les institutions les budgets et les
politiques communautires ainsi qu'au
fait qu'il implique déjà un fort
investissement politique et économique
pour l'ou malgré malgré notre soutien
déterminé à l'élargissement nous
soulignons l'importance de rester très
axé sur les mérites des candidats qui
garantissent que les pays candidats sont
prêts à devenir membres en ce qui
concerne les réformes de ces processus
que ces processus impliquent l'Espagne
s'est positionné en faveur de la
promotion du débat et est ouverte à une
conversation franche sur les réonds de
TT et une réflexion sur les
fonctionnements futur des loué y compris
l'impact que l'élargissement aura sur
son fonctionnement nous attendons les
rapports d'impact sur la PAC la cohésion
et les affaires institutionnels qui
seront présentés au cours de ces
semestrees par la commission merci
beaucoup
merci beaucoup monsieur Elder Carvallo
Joanna chef de mission adjointe de
l'ambassade du Portugal votre pays est
l'un des plus éloignés géographiquement
de la frontière orientale de l'Union
européenne mais a toujours soutenu les
élargissements successifs et c'est
toujours beaucoup engagé dans le
fonctionnement des institutions
européennes c'est à Lisbonne qui a été
signé le traité qui a permis à l'Union
européenne d'avancer après un trou d'air
historique votre pays conjugue ce
semestre une campagne électorale
nationale en mars et la campagne
européenne en juin l'élargissement
fait-il partie des sujets à l'ordre du
jour merci Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
mesdames la les sénatrices monsieurs les
les sénateurs mesdames et monessieurs
les ambassadeurs merci pour cette
invitation tout d'abord euh c'est c'est
un honneur pour pour nous tous je crois
de d'avoir l'opportunité de discuter
ensemble en sujet si important pour
notre avenir collective euh comme vous
l'avez dit monsieur le Président le
Portugal a beaucoup bénéficié de son
processus d'intégration nous en sommes
fiers euh et euh c'est aussi pour cette
raison euh comme vous l'avez dit nous
soutenons l'élargissement bien sûr dans
le respect des principes qui sont déjà
bien attablis et bien connus de tous
tout on été conscient de la complexité
de cet exercice nous avons toujours
plaidé pour la nécessité de parler
franchement mais aussi de tenir nos
promesses que ce soit envers l'Ukraine
ou les Balcans occidentaux euh dans le
contexte géopolitique actuel débat sur
l'élargissement est inévitable et les
décisions déjà prises par le Conseil
européen sont clair sur la direction à
suivre nous les soutenons bien sûr les
chefs d'État et de gouvernement ont
également souligné la nécessité pour
l'Union européenne de débattre
simultanément du processus en terme de
réforme nécessaire pour la préparer à
cette nouvelle phase le Portugal a
toujours soutenu cette synchronisation
et nous nous félicitons que cela soit
maintenant la position commune de nous
tous
cette double ambition signifie que le
que les progrès dans le processus
d'adhésion des pays candidats doivent
être en phase avec les réformes
nécessaires que l'Union européenne doit
entreprendre pour accueillir des
nouveaux membres et fonctionner
efficacement avec plus de 30 pays
soutenir l'élargissement tout en faisant
face au défis qu'il apportera est donc
essentiel ignorer ces problème ne fait
que retarder l'insertion complète des
pays candidats dans le projet européen
en si le nouvel élan en faveur de la
politique d'élargissement doit également
être accompagné d'un effort similaire
pour restructurer l'Union européenne
notamment et ça a déjà été dit par
beaucoup d'entre nous au niveau de ces
de ces principales politiques communes
de son budget et de ses règles de
fonctionnement sur la révision des
traités qui a été beaucoup abordé aussi
aujourd'hui nous croyons qu'avant tout
on doit décider qu type d'Union
européenne nous voulons avant de
discuter et dans entr dans un processus
qui est si complexe et difficile à
aboutir en 2 minutes monsieur le
Président voilà notre position que je
crois que c'est que c'est largement
partagé je vous remercie encore une fois
pour cette opportunité
merci par référendum le 1er juin 2022 à
une large majorité la levée de l'option
de retrait l'optout pour permettre la
pleine participation à la politique de
sécurité et de défense commune ainsi
qu'une augmentation des crédits de
défense sur la période
2018-2023 20 plus 20 % en 2023 soit 1,5
% de votre PIB soutiens de longues dates
de l'Ukraine et des Balcans occidentaux
résolument engagé dans la résolution des
crises gardien des fameux critères de
Copenhague comment votre pays voit-il le
lien entre élargissement et réforme de
l'Union
européenne merci monsieur le Président
Mesdames monsieurs les sénateurs chers
collègues euh merci pour cette
opportunité
d'échanger les les positions européenne
entre nous et pour être complètement
honnête il y a je pense 10 ou 15 ans la
France et le Danemark ont formé une
alliance avec peu d'autres pays une une
alliance contre les lâchissement
euh les argumentations à l'époque
c'était la capacité d'absorption comme
vous avez mentionné la peur que une une
union héarchie et d'une union plus
faible et mais cette position s'est
changée le 22 février 2022 avec l'invass
russe en Ukraine
euh je pense aussi à copenhag on a
compris
euh le le vrai pouvoir de l'Union
européenne c'est le pouvoir de
l'Attraction et l'attraction vis-à-vis
les les voisin européennes qui euh ne
sont pas encore membres de l'Union et il
faut utiliser cette attraction pour
garder le rôle de l'Europe mondiale mais
surtout vis-à-vis euh les grandes
voisant surtout euh la Russie je suis
personnellement très fier que que cette
décision pris en descembre au Conseil
européen et avec euh le soutien 100 %
euh de du Danemark
euh mais euh une une union rélarchie euh
euh c'est aussi euh une union union
reformée euh
le Danemark ne soutient par des
modifications des traités on a peur
d'une discussion très difficilees entre
les États-membres euh sur les procédures
et et peut-être euh des optout et les
réservations pour d'autres nous sommes
le pays des réservations des optout mais
mais je ne recomment pas une union avec
plusieurs pays avec des des réservations
parce que c'est c'est c'est une comp
complication euh de la coopération et
mais mais c'est possible avec les
les les traités actuels de de de faire
les les réformes nécessaires et et
maintenant le Danemark est en faveur de
de faire des décisions euh par exemple
sur la la politique étrangère et de
sécurité par euh majorité qualifiée
avant
euh nous nous étions contre mais mais
maintenant la gouvernement a décidé
d'être en faveur de faire ces euh
modifications et je pense pour pour les
les précédences euh prochaines euh il y
aura un grand travail avec les réformes
aussi sur les les politiques euh agrico
cohésion et tout ça
euh des discussions difficiles euh nous
nous attendent et et aussi euh sur les
les quatre financières approprié pour
une union rélarchie et le Danemark porte
la précédence le 2e parti de 2025 et
c'est le moment où on a on va commencer
euh les discussions sur les les quatrre
financières multiannuelles euh et et et
j'imagine il y aura des des des
discussions très difficiles mais mais
mais il n'y a aucune choix il faut
trouver des compromis et parce que je
pense l'élchissement c'est c'est une
fête accomplie et et la question c'est
les c'est les dates la population
danoise est est très favorable sur cet
élarchissement et c'est porté par la le
soutien de l'Ukraine euh
euh la population danoise est est très
très très
euh POS
vis-à-vis le
soutien de l'Ukraine l'Ukraine et
aussi d'avoir l'Ukraine comme membre de
l'Union européenne et avec l'Ukraine
aussi la Moldavie et les pays des
Balcans occidentaux c'est c'est c'est
une une une atmosphère positive
évidemment causée par les actions russes
le sentiments au Danemark et ni
seulement anti Poutine mais aussi
antirusse pour le moment et et et c'est
pas désirable mais mais c'est le c'est
le cas merci merci Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur je vais passer maintenant
la parole à Monsieur l'Ambassadeur
d'Irlande monsieur
burgus nous serons très heureux de
rencontrer ce soir le président
du le président du Sénat de la
République d'Irlande qui nous a fait
l'honneur de nous rendre
visite il est il sera là il sera au
cocktail quelle est la perspective de
Dublin sur l'élargissement sachant que
l'adhésion de l'Union européenne à
profond profondément transformé votre
pays merci monsieur le Président chers
sénateurs chers
sénatrice comme l'ont fait mes collègues
je vous remercie pour l'invitation et
pour l'opportunité de partager nos
approches sur cette question importante
et
urgente comme vous l'avez dit il y a 50
ans l'olande faisait partie du tout
premier élargissement de ion
européenne ces 50 dernières années en
tant que membre de l'Union ont
transformé notre économie et notre
société on soutenu notre processus de la
paix et ont amplifié notre impact au
niveau mondial bien plus que ce que nous
aurions pu
imaginer et c'est durant notre
présidence de l'Union européenne en 2004
que nous avons vu le plus grand
élargissement de l'Union avec l'accueil
de 10 nouveaux étatsmembres dans notre
communauté je me souviens très bien
parce que j'ai participé à la cérémonie
à Dublin et 20 ans plus tard l'illande
continue d'être un fervant partisan de
l'élargissement qui a pris une
signification et une urgence nouvelle
avec l'envasion de l'Ukraine en 2
cette invasion a mise en lumière le
besoin d'accroître rapidement notre
soutien et notre coopération pas
seulement avec l'Ukraine mais aussi avec
nos partenaires dans les Balcans
occidentaux ainsi que les partenariat
avec les régions de l'Est et c'est dans
cet esprit que le pechoc irlandais notre
premier ministre a visité le Kosovo le
Montenegro et la
Macédonie semaine dernière durant sa
visite il la rencontré les présidents
des trois pays candidats et il est
persuadé que ces trois pays sont prêts à
s'engager dans la mise en place des
réformes
nécessaires nous devons nous rappeler
que l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne doit se faire sur le mérite
et précédé par des réformes initiées par
les pays candidats euxmême tous les pays
candidats ont encore de travail à
fournir au niveau de ces réformes
c'est notre responsabilité de les aider
dans ce
processus mettre en place les réformes
européennes n'est pas une tâche facile
et nous devons le reconnaître et
soutenir nos partenaires en
conséquence la question n'est plus si
quand mais quand et comment nous devons
continuer à tirer parti de la dynamique
actuel nous devons soutenir avec sérieux
et Constance les pays qui partagent les
valeur commune de l'Union
européenne le soutien de l'Irlande en
faveur de l'élargissement s'accompagne
de la reconnaissance de besoin d'un
engagement sérieux sérieux pour une
réforme de
l'Union les implications de
l'élargissement seront nombreuses et ne
se limiteront pas aux questions
budgétaires et
programmatiques nous devrons aussi nous
pencher sur nos capacités internes et
les processus de prise de décision et
cela applique s'applique entre autres à
la question de vote à la majorité
qualifiée et appelle à un renforcement
de son
usage nous sommes ouvertes à des
discussions pour un plus grand recours à
la majorité qualifiée dans les domaines
tels que la politique étrangère et de
sécurité commune tout en reconnaissant
les divergences de point de vue de nos
partenaires sur ce ce sujet mais on ne
peut dter de l'intérêt pour l'Union
européenne de s'exprimer d'une seule et
même voix sur la scène internationale
particulièrement aujourd'hui merci
monsieur le
Président merci beaucoup Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur madame
catherineosdempen ministre directrice du
service politique de l'ambassade
d'Allemagne nous avons auditionné il y a
peu votre ambassadeur nous avons eu des
échange très sincère et approfondi hors
caméra nous savons le le rôle moteur de
votre pays en faveur des réformes et de
l'action commune franco-allemande et que
l'action commune franco-allemande est
cruciale pour nous bien sûr sur un enjeu
de cette importance merci de nous
rappeler le point de vue de
Berlin merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs merci aussi pour
cette invitation autour de ce thème
important et merci aussi pour votre
introduction aimable euh
le gouvernement fédéral a pleinement
soutenu l'ouverture de négociations
d'adhésion avec l'Ukraine c'est une
question de solidarité avec le peuple
ukrainien mais aussi un test de notre
crédibilité et de notre fermeté dans la
défense de nos valeurs communes cela
vaut aussi pour la Moldavie ainsi que
pour les décisions prises concernant la
geéorgie et la
bosnieherzgovine notre ministre des
Affaires étrangères Analena berbock a
été très clair que face à la guerre d'AG
russe l'élargissement de l'Union
européenne est une nécessité
géopolitique comme beaucoup de collègues
d'ailleurs l'ont déjà mentionné elle a
aussi souligner l'importance de
pleinement préparer l'Union européenne à
l'adhésion de nouveaux membres ce
processus de réforme prendra beaucoup de
temps et c'est pourquoi pour bien
encadrer ce
processus et pour élaborer et mettre en
œuvre des réformes nécessaires il est
nécessaire de définir une feuille de
route très
concrète il ne doit pas y avoir de
concession concernant l'état de droit
notre avis qui est un fondement de notre
union donc concrètement il s'agit de
lier encore plus systématiquement les
versements de fonds européens au respect
des normes de l'État de droit la
ministre a également fait un appel à
trouver un moyen de ne pas agrandir la
Commission et pour cela nous serions
même prêt à nous passer temporairement
d'un commissaire allemand du point de
vue allemand 36 véau c'est trop ça a été
déjà mentionné par plusieurs collègues
l'Allemagne propose également d'élargir
le champ des décision à la majorité
qualifiée notamment pour les questions
de finances et de politique étrangère
euh à notre avis pour la politique
étrangère de l'Union européenne nous
avons besoin de compétences claires d'un
visage et d'une voix l'Allemagne reste
pleinement engagée de travailler
ensemble avec la France et avec nos
partenaires pour rendre notre Europe
plus forte agile et solidaire dans un
monde marqué par une concurrence
croissante des systèmes politiques merci
de vre attention merci monsieur
de l'ambassade d'Italie à Paris votre
pays soutient ardemment l'élargissement
au Balcans occidentaux en particulier
quel rôle joue aujourd'hui l'Italie pays
fondateur pour faire progresser la
dynamique conjointe de l'élargissement
et des
réformes merci beaucoup monsieur le
Président Mesdames les sénatrices
messieurs les sénateurs Mesdames et
Messieurs chers collègues merci de cette
opportunité d'iler les positions de nos
pays sur des questions qui sont en fait
qui sont en fait aujourd'hui
fondamentales pour pour l'avenir de
l'Union européenne et seulement un mot
je mon ambassadice m prie de vous dire
de l'excuser pour ne pas être là ce soir
mais il y avait un événement public à
l'ambassade programmé depuis très
longtemps donc elle n'a pas pu venir
comme vous le Rappelz monsieur le
Président l'Italie traditionnellement
est parmi les pays les plus convaincu
dans le soutiens au processus
d'élargissement nous som nous nous
considérons peut-être un peu en tant que
pays du traité de Rome disons les
gardiens de l'esprit de de l'Union
européenne et de l'idée de compléter
l'Union européenne évitant en évitant de
laisser des vides qui euh risquent
malheureusement des vides géographiques
qui risquent d'être remplis par des
acteurs qui ne sont pas forcément
amiables et bien disposés envers envers
nous ça veut dire et là aussi vous
rappeler une attention spéciale que nous
avons toujours eu pour les Balcans
occidentaux qui est dans notre opinion
une région stratégique pour l'Italie
autant que pour toute l'Europe et qu
plusieurs de de mes collègues qui ont
parlé à M moi leuront rappelé l'histoire
de NS de notre continent nous le
rappelle de la Première Guerre mondiale
à la dissolution de
laexyoslavie sur les processus de
l'argissement évidemment il s'agit d'un
processus qui doit être fondé sur les
mérites mais qui ne peut pas négliger
les implications géostratégiques qui
sont devenues absolument évidentes après
la la l'agression russe à l'Ukraine
c'est pourquoi nous avons soutenu avec
conviction l'ouverture de négociation
d'adhion avec de avec l'Ukraine et la la
moldovie la concession du statut de pays
candidat à la Georgie au dernier conseil
européen et maintenant nous somt prêts à
faire tout les possi pour soutenir ces
pays dans les parcours de de réformes
qui sont indispensables pour devenir
membres de de l'Union
européenne évidemment en passant à la
deème question la per effective d'une
Union européenne avec 35 ou 36 membres
nous impose une réflexion sur la
nécessité de réforme des instidtuctions
et des politique de l'Union européenne
pour éviter une paralyse de l'activité
de la de l'Union et assurer que P il
puisse continuer à fonctionner autant
d'un point de vue institutionnel que que
par les biais des politiques qui ont
connu pendant les derniers 70 ans un
énorme succès comme la la politique
agricole commune la politique de
cohésion la recherche et et et et toutes
les autres donc il s'agit de deux
parcours que doivent d'un are qui
doivent d'un notre vision procéder en
parallèle le processus d'élection et et
les processus de réformes il y a
évidemment beaucoup de questions qui
devront être
affronté auxquelles nous nous devrons
faire face et et une plus je ne peux pas
comment dire résumer toutes mais
peut-être une des plus importants ce
sera en fait la question du budget pour
donner à l'Union les moyens pour être
efficace dans son action et et ça veut
dire pour nous tout d'abord avoir aussi
des ressources propres d'une dimension
qui nous permett de d'échapper au débat
traditionnel sur quels sont les pays
contributeurs net qui sont les pays qui
reçoivent de plus et passer disons à à à
une autre dimension de l' sortir de la
logique de la Somme zéro dans réflexion
merci beaucoup merci alors si je voulais
tous vous vexer je dirais qu'on garde le
meilleur pour la fin mais ça n'est pas
mon intention et je vais tout de suite
passer la parole à Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de du Grand her du
Luxembourg autre fondateur et le siège
de nombreuses et importantes
institutions européennes nous allons de
temps en temps votre point de vue est
particulièrement attendu sur les
réformes à
préconiser merci monsieur le Président
madamees les sénatrices monsieurs les
sénateurs je vais essayer de vous
résumer la position du Luxembourg donc
en résumé nous le Luxembourg soutient la
la nouvelle dynamique du du processus
d'élargissement nous souscrivons à à
cette nouvelle approche que
l'élargissement est un investissement
géostratégique dans la paix la sécurité
la stabilité la prospérité cependant
pour nous il est aussi d'une importance
capitale que le processus reste basé sur
le
mérite nous croyons aussi qu'il faut
éviter toute idée d'un système
d'élargissement à deux
[Musique]
niveaux tous les pays candidat doivent
être évalués en fonction de leur propre
mérite
euh chaque pays doit mettre en place les
réformes
nécessaires et pour nous il faut porter
un accent par parulier sur l'état de
droit on résumé donc l'élargissement
bien que se déroulant dans dans un
contexte géopolitique ou géostratégique
doit rester un processus basé sur le
mérite pour ce qui est des des
réformes il est clair pour que ce cet
élargissement soit un succès que l'Union
européenne doit également mettre en
place ces réformes nous parce que nos
institutions et toutes nos politiquesiv
doivent continuer euh de fonctionner
dans dans dans la nouvelle Europe
élargie donc nous avons nous sommes pour
comme d'autres collègues l'ont dire pour
un processus que les deux processus
élargissement
et réforme se se déroule de de manière
parallèle et concrètement si si on parle
de de déroulement parallèle ou en
parallèle pour nous il il il est
important que les deux processus chacun
se déroule à son propre rythme
c'est-à-dire que nous voulons éviter
toute automatisation entre les deux
processus euh nous devons donc nous
appeler
analyser l'impact de de de
l'élargissement sur le budget de l'Union
européenne la PAC les fond de cohésion
et cetera nous nous contribuons de de
manière constructive à à tout toutes ces
discussions il est un point sur lequel
je voudrais insister pour nous il est
particulièrement important de poursuivre
cette réflexion de manière inclusive et
transparente
euh donc je voudrais encore attirer
l'attention sur deux critères qui sont
importants pour nous euh euh toute toute
toute réforme et tout élargissement pour
les deux ils doivent contribuer au
renforcement de l'Union européenne et
garantir sa stabilité et sa
prospérité donc ceci veut dire il ne
faut pas perdre de vue les fondamentaux
de l'Union européenne et passage nous
entendons euh euh qu'il faut défendre
l'acqui communautaire tel que le marché
intérieur l'espace Schengen et encore
une fois je l'ai déjà dit l'État de
droit alors pour ce qui est la réforme
des règles institutionnelles euh comme
d'autres collègues ici nous croyons que
si possible on doit se baser sur les
dispositions qui figurent déjà dans le
dans le traité nous nous croyons qu'
historiquement il est très difficile de
faire une nouvelle convention parce
qu'après ce sera un processus difficile
et le processus de ratification d'un
nouveau traité serait encore plus
difficile merci les traités c'est comme
le cerveau on utilise que 10
% bien écoutez merci merci de vous être
prê
de vous être prêté au jeu
euh d'ailleurs ça n'était pas un jeu
c'était vraiment très intéressant de
d'avoir vos vos points de vue on va
maintenant passer la parole à nos
rapporteurs sur l'élargissement parce
qu'on a voyez on creuse la question
vraiment sur le fond au Sénat pour
apporter à nos collègues les meilleures
informations possibles et donc je vais
passer la parole donc à Claude KNE à
Didier Marie
je sais pas Claude tu devais aller en
séance aprè je pense donc à Claude kerme
Didier Marie et puis à
Martin merci Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
pour vos explications alors je vais
aller droite au but comme on dit pas
dans mon le club de foot que je je
supporte mais dans un autre
euh vous demandez à votre avis quelle
conséquence de l'élargissement de l'UE
quelles sont les conséquences pardon de
l'élargissement de l'ueuse pour le
budget européen et les politiques
communes plus importantes comme la
politique agricole commune ou la
politique de cohésion et puis une
deuxième question sur les pays candidats
et je m'attacherai principalement à
l'Ukraine face au risque de l'assitude
des européens mais aussi de la
population ukrainienne se durement
éprouvé après 2 ans de guerre et malgré
malgré les difficultés évidentes de
contreoffensive ukrainienne comment
poursuivre le plus efficacement possible
le soutien politique financier et
militaire à l'Ukraine tout en l'incitant
à défendre le mieux possible les valeurs
communes de la démocratie et de l'État
de droit comment accompagner ce pays
dans la mise en œuvre des réformes
indispensables dans le cadre de la
méthodologie au pilotage plus politique
réversible et fondé sur les sur les
mérites pardon voilà je vais m'arrêter
là merci président d'abord je voudrais
vous remercier à mon tour mesdames et
messieurs les représentants des
États-membres de de vos propos c'est
vrai que c'est difficile en l'espace
d'un temps aussi contraint de
développer une argumentation sur cette
question sensible de l'élargissement euh
moi j'ai j'ai noté surtout un grand
nombre de convergenenceces sur le fait
qu'on était face à un défi historique
c'était une question vitale pour la
démocratie et que c'était une
nécessité stratégique et et et
géopolitique et qu'il était plus
aujourd'hui question de savoir si
l'Union européenne allait s'élargir même
peut-être pas quand mais surtout comment
nous allions nous y prendre
euh le premier constat que que l'on fait
je crois collectivement c'est que
l'approche qui a fait ses preuves en en
2004 lors du Big Bang qui a permis à 10
pays d'entrer et de toute évidence
inadaptée aujourd'hui et qu'il faut donc
inventer une nouvelle méthode
euh à la fois pour permettre aux pays
candidats de nous rejoindre le plus vite
possible en respectant ce que vous avez
dit les principes mêmes et les valeurs
qui sont celles de l'Union européenne
une adhésion au mérite plusieurs d'entre
vous l'ont cité je crois que c'est
fondamental en respectant bien
évidemment les grands principes de
l'État de droit et de la démocratie et
je pense que c'est d'ailleurs la pierre
angulaire de toute cette stratégie
d'élargissement qu'il conviendra de
rappeler en permanence à à à chaque
étape mais c'est aussi d'entreprendre
les réformes institutionnelles
nécessaires sans pour autant que cela
servent de prétexte à bloquer le
processus d'adhésion car on voit bien
que ça pourrait être un un un élément
moi j'ai noté qu'une certaine unanimité
se dégage entre vous pour ne pas
réouvrir les traités euh ce que l'on
peut partager dans le contexte actuel au
regard de la défiance d'une partie de
nos concitoyens à l'égard des
institutions européennes et et sachant
qu'il faudra passer par référendum c'est
donc un un risque majeur que l'on ne
peut peut-être pas courir actuellement
mais euh on peut tout de même
s'interroger euh sur la nécessité à un
moment donné de réouvrir les traités de
se demander si ça sera plus facile quand
on sera 35 ou 36 et et j'aimerais
peut-être à un moment donné que vous
puissiez réagir à cette réflexion euh on
ne peut pas faire l'économie d'une
réforme chacune et chacun l'a dit euh
les gouvernements français et allemands
par l'intermédiaire de leur ministre des
affaires européennes avaient mandaté un
groupe d'experts 12 experts qui devaient
faire des propositions je vais savoir ce
que vous pensez de la feuille de route
qu'ils ont préconisé euh considérant que
pour un certain nombre d'entre vous vous
avez déjà esquissé quelques réponses sur
le sujet notamment pour le passage pour
la majorité décision de la règle de
l'unanimité la règle de la majorité
qualifiée euh avec des divergences
semble-t-il entre ceux qui considèrent
que ça ne doit pas
concerner les questions de politique
étrangère et de sécurité commune et
d'autres qui sont prêts aujourd'hui
semble-t-il à envisager que ça puisse le
faire j'aimerais aussi avoir des
éclaircissements sur la future
organisation de la commission parce qu'à
35 ou à 36 ça fait beaucoup de
commissaires est-ce que chacun devrait
avoir un portefeuille plein et entier ou
est-ce que vous imaginez une
organisation différenciée tout en
permettant à chaque pays d'avoir sa part
enfin euh que pensez-vous de
l'opportunité de rééquilibrer les
relations entre les trois institutions
européennes et notamment en donnant plus
de place au Parlement européen en
instituant un principe de codécision
pour un grand nombre de celle-ci et de
lui donner aussi un un pouvoir
d'initiative et de la même façon quelle
place souhaitez-vous donner au Parlement
européen dans un processus qui s'ouvre
au Parlement pardon nationaux dans un
processus qui s'ouvre notamment en en
donnant à ces parlements nationaux une
capacité d'initiative avec le fameux
carton vert dont on parle beaucoup mais
qui n'a jamais pu aboutir euh voilà je
partage aussi ce que vous avez dit sur
la nécessité des moyens pour accueillir
nos futurs partenaires ce n'est pas un
budget constant qu' pour pourra y
arriver ça nécessite de réfléchir au
futur budget européens et notamment au
aux ressources propres donc là aussi
quelles sont les positions de de de vos
pays je pense pas qu'on ait le temps de
tout traiter aujourd'hui mais ce sont
les questions qu'on pourra
vraisemblablement avoir avoir
ultérieurement merci à vous merci Didier
Mara Sidrac oui merci Président Mesdames
et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs merci
beaucoup de vous être prêté à cette
exercice qui n'était pas simple mais
fort intéressant moi je retiendrai
quelques termes qui revenaient dans vos
différents propos euh notamment sur le
processus graduel lié aussi au mérit des
pays candidats je crois que c'est
quelque chose effectivement que nous
pouvons partager tous ensemble euh nous
nous ce sont des interrogations que que
l'on a souvent ici euh je vous avais
aussi évoqué la notion de réversibilité
introduite dans cette nouvelle
méthodologie pour ces pays candidat et
je crois que c'est un point aussi qui
est important à soulever et à rappeler
d'autant plus que la France n'était pas
tout à fait étrangère à cette nouvelle
méthodologie pour les pays candidats
mais vous avez aussi évoqué solidarité
vous avez parlé équilibre vous avez
parlé aussi stabilité je crois que c'est
effectivement des notions qui sont très
importantes à rappeler et on sent que
autour de ces de ces mots mais aussi de
ces notions il se dégage une forme de
consensus entre les différents pays et
moi à titre personnel je ne que m'en
réjouir je je ne reviendrai pas sur les
propos qui ont déjà été partagés par mes
collègues l'un de vous aussi a parlé de
vide géographique en fait sans les pays
des Balcans je crois que c'était vous
monsieur Cassio représentant de l'Italie
et c'est vrai que effectivement
aujourd'hui lorsqu'on est européen
lorsqu'on regarde le continent européen
il nous est difficile d'imaginer que B
qu'un morceau de de cette terre commune
ne puisse pas éventuellement faire
partie de ces cette union européenne à
laquelle beaucoup aspirent et notamment
les peuples en fait je crois que c'est
une notion aussi des peuples que que
l'on ne doit pas obliger donc moi
j'aurais en fait une question qui n'a
pas encore été tout à fait abordée qui a
été évoquée par le président rppin
puisque à la fin de l'année dernière il
y a eu le plan d'investissement et de
croissance qui a été annoncé avec 6
milliards donc moi j'aurais souhaité à
voir si cela était possible contte tenu
du du nombre que vous êtes hein donc je
ne sais pas comment la réponse pourrait
formaliser monsieur le Président mais je
te laisserai gérer tout cela euh comment
est-ce que voilà comment est-ce que cela
pourrait être mis en œuvre dans quel
délai comment est-ce que vous voyez
cette articulation qui reste néanmoins
un exercice relativement complexe voilà
je ne serai pas plus longue et je vous
remercie merci alors je ne vais pas vous
redonner à tous la parole sur toutes les
questions qui m'ont été posées
d'ailleurs préalablement aux questions
posées vous avez déjà en grande partie
pour les uns et les autres répondu à ces
à ces questions mais surtout par rapport
aux remarques de nos rapporteurs il y en
a-t-il parmi vous qui qui veuillent
ajouter quelque chose ou ou qui
souhaitent apporter un complément à leur
propos qui irait dans le sens des
questions
oui allez-y madame seulement un petit
point concret puisqu'il était question
de du soutien à l'Ukraine enfin vous
avez vous avez certainement suivi les
annonce du chancelier mais en plus je
voulais vous informer que l'Allemagne
organisera ensemble avec l'Ukraine une
une conférence pour la reconstruction de
l'Ukraine à Berlin le 11 et 12
juin intéressant
merci alors non pas d'éléments
complémentaires nos rapporteurs
[Musique]
resteront avec leur questions
oui ma question évidemment porté plus
spécifiquement sur les balcons
occidentaux excusez-moi je ne l'ai pas
précisé puisque vous avez aussi beaucoup
parlé vous faites bien de le rappeler
madame
l'ambassadrice il y a le sujet
évidemment l'Ukraine Moldavie et Georgie
mais ma question portait plus
spécifiquement sur les Balcans
occidentaux alors je vais donner
monsieur Cassio vous vouliez vous
exprimer oui merci donc sur la question
spécifique du plein pour
lainvestisement et croissance pour les
Balcans c'est un plein que nous
soutenons évidemment comme tous les
efforts de d'accompagner les proc
processus d'adhésion de rapprochement
des pays des Balcans à l'Union
européenne et donc la se chose que de
notre point devue on souhaite une
implication majeure des étatsmembres
dans la gouvernance du plan des
croissance parce on pense qu'il a une
expertise une compétence destats membres
qui pourrait être exploité dans
la voilà dans le développement de ce
plan mais en principe on les soutient
avec
conviction
merci Monsieur alexier
Junas merci beaucoup c'est vraiment
grand vaste des questions pour répondre
peut-être mais je voudrais vraiment
peut-être sur deux points qui ét
mentionnés le premier point sur bien sû
les conséquences d'élergissement à venir
je pense vous avez mentionné le les
propositions de 12 experts franco
allemand mais je voudrais vraiment
insister que c'était aussi un processus
un peu parallèle qui a été organisé par
le sa SP de l'Université de Vilnus des
professeurs avec quelques collègues du
pays nordique et du pays de notre région
et nous onons aussi proposé la
proposition un peu une parallèle qui a
été présentée par notre vice-ministre au
conseil de des Affaires étrangères
pendant la discussion sur sur la base de
de 12 experts donc je pense c'est aussi
un peu de document qui peut-être pas
très connu mais quand même il y a un peu
de propositions de notre côté pour la
réforme de l'Europe et aussi pour euh
pour l'égissement de de l'Union
européenne euh pour pour les
conséquences de de d'élergissement bien
sûr ça sera la conséquence
deélergissement ça sera le prix
d'élergissement mais quel est quel sont
les les alternatifes euh pour moi les
alternatives plus coûteurs pour pour
laisser ces pays de dehors l'Union
européenne pour avoir le des régions pas
très stable pour avoir des problèmes
avec avec notre voisinage donc notre
calculation que c'est c'est plus
peut-être économiquement et
politiquement pour intégrer les les pays
qui sont qui qui sont prêts pour prêtes
pour vraiment venir à l'un européen pour
partager nos valeurs et pour contribuer
pour l'Europe plus fort donc c'est un
peu de choix bien sûr il a il a
conséquence il a le prix et mais il faut
vraiment pas faire le
obstacle pour pour pour lgissement c'est
cette décision qui est vraiment est
nécessaire faire au niveau européen
c'est notre tâche maintenant pour
discuter pour trouver les solutions et
comme j'ai dit dans mon discours au
début il faut avoir plus de confiance
qu'il faut on peut vraiment trouver la
solution c'était la peut-être aussi
difficile pour notre égissement c'était
du pays c'était vraiment peut-être les
conséquences plus larges qui on pu
imaginer avec l'Ukraine et les autres
pays parce que c'était vraiment 10
nouveaux pays avec beaucoup beaucoup
de de différence ce qui con niveau
économique mais quand même l'Union
Européen a trouvé la solution comment
intégrer comment trouver les le le
processus de légissement et comme j'ai
dit la Lituanie peut-être le meilleur
exemple de cette réussit des politiques
d'gissement deè point sur l'Ukraine
comment comment peut-être pour suivre
comment avoir la continuité pour
l'assistance pour
l'Ukraine je pense bien sûr il a la
question de assistance militaire
maintenant le plus plus important
comment on peut vraiment donner la
assistance militaire pour les Ukrainiens
parce
que c'est pas que l'Europe a déjà fait
tout les que l'Europe peut
faire économie de la guerre n'existe pas
je pense maintenant en Europe j'ai
visité plusieurs interprise français
pour moi c'est une vraiment un
indicateur qui maintenant juste commence
peut-être étion comment on peut élargir
la coopération au niveau européen entre
les industries de la défense comment on
peut vraiment euh pousser production de
ammonition au niveau européen et cetera
et cetera mais ça prendre un peu de
temps mais il faut vraiment pousser
l'Europe vers cette direction pour avoir
plus de compétences pour avoir plus de
pouvoir pour pour aider les Ukrainiens
au niveau de de la défense de sécurité
et puis bien sûr général
géopolitiquement
l'intégration de l'raine à l'Union
européne à l' temp c'est la Meille
réponse pour ptine c'est la meilleure
réponse pour la Russie pour d'être très
clair qu'il n'y a aucune question sur
l'avenir de l'ra en Europe et ça le
message que Poutine peut
comprendre merci vous avez parlé
d'industrie et d'industrie de l'armement
en particulier et demain matin et pour
votre information nous nous recevons en
audition commissaire breton ici au
Sénat je vais demander je vais me
tourner vers mes cèg
savoir s'ils ont des éléments
éventuellement apportés ou peut-être des
questions précises ah Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur voulez oui un peu tardif
pardon mais je voulais juste commenter
un peu ou répondre à la question de
madame la sénatrice en ce qui concerne
le plan de croissance malheureusement je
ne peux pas vous offrir les réponses en
ce qui concerne la méthodologie de de de
de l'implantation de ce plan mais de
toute façon ce plan
était saluer euh avec enthousiasme par
notre ministre parce qu'il dit que c'est
précisément ça qu'il faut faire afin de
d'assurer le une situation équitable
parce que le le plan inclut eu selon mes
informations aussi une intégration plus
étroite dans le marché intérieur qui est
déjà en place pour l'Ukraine et la
Moldavie mais pas encore pour la plupart
des pays des Balcans occidentaux alors
c'est ce plan-là est précisément une
étape très appréciée par
l'Autriche merci donc je reprends Renand
logle merci monsieur le Président membre
de la commission et je le précise
président du groupe d'amitié
France-Allemagne merci monsieur le
Président Mesdames Messieurs les
Ambassadeurs permettez-moi tout d'abord
de de saluer l'initiative du du
président de la commission des affaires
européennes Jean-François rppin pour
cette rencontre absolument nécessaire et
importante
et dans le cadre de la commission des
affaires étrangères et de la défense
nous sommes rendus fin décembre à Kief
et précédemment en Pologne évidemment la
question de l'élargissement à la Pologne
a été un des éléments qui a été évoqué
et on a senti évidemment qu'il y a une
certaine inquiétude notamment sur le
volet de la politique agricole commune
que pourrait être une Ukraine membre de
l'Union européenne enfin que
pourrait-être la politique agricole
commune d'une Ukraine membre de l'Union
européenne et ça pose évidemment une
question fondamentale notre conviction
c'est que d'un point de vue
géostratégique le
le offrir à
l'Ukraine la perspective de l'adhésion
est absolument indispensable contenu
finalement des des valeurs fondamentales
qui sont celles de l'État de droit de la
démocratie et que aujourd'hui les
Ukrainiens défendent c'est de ça dont il
est question donc l'enjeu est absolument
crucial c'est la raison pour laquelle
nous sommes en soutien total à l'Ukraine
néanmoins il va falloir sans doute R
inventer la politique agricole commune
si ça devait advenir est-ce que ça fait
partie de des réflexions qui sont
actuellement en cours dans vos pays je
vous
remercie merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs mesdames les
ambassadeurs ambassadries alors bon
ronant legleu a a parlé d'un certain
nombre de points que je voulais évoquer
mais j'aiis trois questions principales
une première sur la nécessité de de
réviser certaines politiques très
intégrées je pense particulièrement à la
PAC certains d'entre vous l'ont évoqué
avant l'ouverture des marchés à d'autres
pays et donc au-delà des réformes
institutionnelles on aura aussi besoin
de mener des réformes sectoriel comment
envisagez-vous donc ces réformes
nécessaires et qui semblent nécessair en
terme de de temps en terme de timing
avant le prochain cadre financier
pluriannuel si on veut avancer sur les
questions de d'élargir isement peut-être
que les ambassadeurs notamment de de de
la Pologne de la Slovaquie veulent
réagir sur ces éléments puisque vous
avez aussi été ces derniers mois très
impactés dans vos politiques intérieures
par par ces questions notamment par le
passage des des céréales russes par par
vos pays et puis aussi élargir la focale
à l'autre côté de l'Atlantique avec les
élections américaines et l'inquiétude
autour de la possibilité d'une
réélection de Donald Trump et euh des
des des perspectives d'instabilité de la
politique étrangère américaine qui en
découlerait et qui représente un risque
important aussi pour l'Union européenne
et notre politique étrangère et ce qui
donnera aussi une certaine urgence à la
nécessité de de réformer l'Union et
d'avancer sur les questions de la pesque
euh donc au-delà de la majorité des
possibilités de majorité qualifié sur la
pesque pesque quelle autre piste
envisagez-vous pour éviter les blocages
alors qu'il faudra dans le casreun
élection de Donald Trump avancer
rapidement vers une plus forte
intégration européenne en matière de
défense euh et puis un un point
peut-être autour de de de la manière
dont on doit envisager la participation
et de des concitoyens de nos concitoyens
partout dans l'Union européenne euh face
à l'élargissement puisque euh pour
réussir cet élargissement il faudra
aussi convaincre les populations
européennes de nos de nos différents
pays euh euh euh de de voilà de du du
bien fondé de d'un élargissement et on
sait que aujourd'hui ça ça reste aussi
compliqué dans un certain nombre de pays
donc voilà et sinon j'avais juste un un
commentaire sur l'état de droit puisque
plusieurs d'entre vous l'ont mentionné
pour dire que c'est vrai que
l'intransigence doit aussi être de mise
pour avancer de manière coordonnée à
l'échelle européenne et et on ne pourra
pas avancer dans l'intégration sans
mécanisme plus fort pour garantir le
respect de l'État de droit par les
États-membres merci Catherine main Deli
pour une question très courte et après
je laisse la parole à Monsieur
l'Ambassadeur de Suède merci Président
Mesdames et Messieurs les Ambassadeurs
une question extrêmement courte pour
compléter les questions de mes collègues
la crise sanitaire et plus récemment
bien sûr la la la la guerre qui s'est
invité aux portes de laarope avec toutes
ses conséquences économiques pour et de
sécurité pour notre continent nous ont
fait prendre conscience de nos carences
de nos dépendances dangereuses et nous
invite à sursaut notamment en matière de
de politique industrielle de retrouver
une forme d'autonomie stratégique une
forme de souveraineté la souveraineté ne
voulons pas dire non plus le
protectionnisme et l'enfermement et le
repli vers nous-même mais une une
stratégie comment dirais-je d'avenir sur
quel sujet dans vos pays respectifs
justement travaillez-vous dans ce sens
d'une de retrouver une plus grande
autonomie stratégique en matière
notamment de politique industrielle
j'aurais aimé le le savoir et que vous
le partagez avec nous
merci merci beaucoup merci pour toutes
ces questions très pertinentes mais pas
toujours très facile euh juste de de de
remarques sur les conséquences
budgétaires à Stockholm il y a un
travail en cours pour réfléchir sur les
implications de de l'élargissement euh
mais on peut bien entendu imaginer que
l' gissement au moins à long terme un
jour affectera les politiques de lieu et
nécessitera des réformes des politiques
les plus plus coûteux en terme
budgétaire et donc la PAC et la
politique de cohésion ont déjà été euh
mentionné en ce qui concerne le soutien
à l'Ukraine
euh comme mes collègues ont déjà dit euh
il faut encore augmenter euh cette aide
euh
il faut le faire dans la durée euh comme
mon collègue lituanien a déjà mentionné
le soutien militaire est peut-être
l'aide la plus importante en ce moment
il faut des garanties de sécurité aussi
et puis des programmes pour soutenir les
réformes les efforts de de réforme et
aussi la reconstruction et ça va coûter
très très cher pour le contribuable
européen
euh et fait tout cela déjà en quelque
sorte mais il faut faire plus et encore
une fois il faut le faire dans la durée
merci je CIS pas aussitôt donc non sur
la question du budget qui est
revenue dans plusieurs des questions qui
ont été
posées il me semble de revenir dans les
passés parce qu'avant de venir ici à
Paris j'étais à Bruxelles j'ai négocié à
Bruxelles les cadre financier plusannuel
les paquets de relance donc et je crois
que il faudrait pas se poser la question
en terme des conséquen de de de
l'élargissement sur les budgets et les
politiques de l'Union le problème c'est
de décider quelle est l'union européenne
que nous voulons avoir queles sont les
ambitions que nous avons et après une
fois qu'on a défini les ambitions nous
donner les moyens pour réussir à à à à
atteindre nos ambitions parce que euh on
a déjà vu en 2004 la situation des pays
de l'Union européenne a changé après
l'élargissement par rapport au budget
l'Italie était un contributeur net avant
2004 est devenu le 3è pardon était un
bénéficiaire net est devenu un
contributeur net à partir de 2004 les 3e
de l'Union européenne et on a vu aussi
avec la crise covid et avec la
l'agression de la Russie à l'Ukraine
toute l'utilité de disposer
d'instruments et de politiques que
pendant très longtemps pent été critiqué
disons et je pense à la politique
agricole commune on pensait que l'idée
de la souveraineté alimentaire c'était
une idée dépassée mais ce qui est arrivé
en Ukraine nous a rappelé que c'est pas
dépassé du tout donc ce sont des
politiques qui sont essentielles pour la
souveraineté stratégique qui est la je
vais répondre mant la sénatrice à un
concept sur lequel euh l'Italie est
absolument convaincu qu'il faut la
développer dans plusieurs secteurs c'est
la défense c'est le premier mais pas
seulement ça parce que c'est aussi de
disposer de exactement de la
souveraineté alimentaire de des
médicaments de tout ce qui nous sert
pour ne pas devoir dépendre de des
sujets qui ne sont pas forcément
intéressés de nous aider dans les
moments des des besoins disons disons
comme ça
et donc euh voilà et une autre chose par
exemple une dernière en dernier point je
me rappelle dans les discussions sur euh
les CADES financiers plannuels et et sur
les paquets deance on disait on parlait
des flexibilité dans les budgets et mon
pays a toujours soutenu l'idée qu'il
faut avoir de la flexibilité du budget
parce qu'on sait jamais c'est qu' r que
ce qui peut arriver non non on a pas
besoin de d'autant de flexibilité et
après il a eu les covid ah bien ok mais
là il a eu les paquet de relance donc
avec ça on a terminé la avec la
flexibilité mais après eu l'Ukraine et
on a vu que les problèmes que nous avons
eu pour soutenir les efforts de de
l'Ukraine de rissance à la Russie et
pour financer l'ucraine vient exactement
du manque de flexibilité dans les dans
les budgets donc la réflexion qu'il
faudra faire de pendant les les les
discussions les négociations pour les
prochains budgets européens attention
tirons les leçons de ce qui nous est
arrivé les budgets est important et il
faut les financer voilà Monsieur
tar merci merci pour pour la question
sur la position de de la Pologne
et je voudrais h mentionner que ce son
pas seulement le question de seral mais
ce sont également les problèm de
transport le protestation à à la
frontière orientale de la Pologne mais
je devrais souligner com je t'ai déjà
dit que ces négociations d'adhésion
seront sûrement complexes et difficiles
parce que pour la Pologne l'agriculture
est toujours très important même même si
c'est
30,5 % de notre produit national brut ça
veut dire seulement 30,5 mais mais c'est
importante pour quelques régions de la
Pologne spécialement de la Pologne
oriental mais je voudrais souligner
que la question de protest station de
des entreprises de transport à la
frontière orientale de Pologne semble
être euh en situation de
d'une solution qui était trouvée je
pense juste aujourd'hui ça veutd ce
blocage de la frontière
et n'est n'est pas plus là n'est pas
plus là c'est c'est c'est c'est une
question et quand s'agit la question de
seral je pense qu'également on peut
trouver une euh solution et je pense que
le la clé pour ça est naturellement euh
une entente interne en Pologne euh et je
sais que maintenant pendant le forum
parce que nous sommes en Pologne
maintenant dans une situation de
cohabitation politique entre le
président et le le nouveau gouvernement
de de la nouvelle coalition euh mais euh
au Forum de Davos aujourd'hui euh
euh le président et le ministre des
Affaires étrangères Radoslav Sikorski
parl de la même voix ça veutd dans
question de d'ouraine ça veut dire je je
suis vraiment sûr que la Pologne va
soutenir l'ouraine va chercher une
solution pas seulement dans la question
des céréales mais des transports
des autres euh questions qui
naturellement par la similarité des des
de
de de l'économie
oukrainienne
polonaise spécialement dans la
agriculture on va vraiment trouver une
une solution viiable pour pour nous et
pour l'Union et pour
l'ouraine
merci merci beaucoup on va peut-être
s'arrêter est là hein puisque voilà ah
vous vouliez dire quelque chose Monsieur
allez- oui un tout petit commentaire euh
je peux répéter ce qu' a dit mon
collègue polonais mais je voudrais
ajouter une seule chose peut-être la
perception des problèmes est différente
de nos pays qui sont voisins de la zone
frontalière des pays parce que si on
parle des problèmes euh de de nos
agriculteurs de nos chauffeurs de
camions en Slovaquie il s'agit de
euh du destin de de cette
euh de cette industrie en Slovaquie pour
vous c'est quelques millions de des
chauffeurs ou quelques centaines des
d'agriculteurs mais pour nous c'est un
problème pour deux trois régions de la
Slovaquie alors c'est un problème
vraiment très très difficile pour mon
gouvernement alors la perception densité
des problèmes différents à Paris
différents à Bratislava monsieur
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur je suis d'autant
plus d'accord avec vous j'ai j'ai posé
une question au gouvernement cet
après-midi sur la pêche et je ne pense
pas qu'en Slovaquie vous soyez sensible
aux questions de pêche mais pourtant
elles ont une dimension européenne très
importante et qui doit être qui doit
être partagée même même avec ceux qui
n'ont pas de qui n'ont pas de côte quand
à quand à la question de l'Ukraine je
comprends aussi qu'elle soit beaucoup
plus sensible chez vous que chez nous
aujourd'hui parce que vous êtes à
proximité voilà quand on discute avec
les Moldaves quand on discute avec les
Roumains quand on discute avec vous moi
je suis allé chez vous
donc je je comprends aussi ça monsieur
l'Ambassadeur merci monsieur le
Président le le le je m'intéresse
particulièrement au sujet évoqué par
madame la sénatrice sur la question
comment assurer l'accord de peuple pour
une décision aussi important que
l'élargissement et je crois qu'il serait
utile un jour de partager nos
expériences parce que on a on a tous
tous ces traditions et ces expériences
en Irlande on utilise un citizens
assembly pour discuter discuter des des
sujets les plus difficiles mais c'est
c'est sûr que le droit de nommer un
membre de la commission touche à la
perception de la la légitimité des
institutions européennes au moins pour
les
je sais je sais très bien que c'est un
combat que vous
menez
bien plus personne bien écoutz voilà ah
oui allez-y monsieur le Président merci
je voudrais seulement ajouter deux notes
aussi à propos des sujets
institutionnels que je crois que nous
convoque à tous c'est c'est plus c'est
toujours des sujets qui
sont euh très discutés et à notre avis
ils sont bien sûr absolument importants
euh mais à notre avis il faut qu'avant
on décide que type d'Union européenne on
veut avoir après l'élargissement mon
premier ministre parle par exemple
dans bâtiment ou il y a un un centre qui
est partagé par tout le monde mais après
il peut avoir des
choix ça dépend bien sûr des intérêts
des priorités des différents
États-membres ça aura bien sûr des
implications aussi institutionnelles
dans les politiques autres des des
politiques communes euh et nous croyons
que euh on doit pas commencer ce débat
par les par les questions
institutionnelles qui sont tellement
divisives et tellement euh difficiles à
mener euh peuvent enulter le débat sur
des sujets si important que que tous les
autres que que nous sommes qui ont été
abordés ici la deuxième chose aussi dans
euh euh comme mon collègue italien a a
dit nous sommes euh aussi très euh euh
conscient des implications que
l'élargissement euh aura c'est clair
pour nous par exemple que on arrêtera
d'être en un bénéficiaire liquide du
budget de l'Union européenne mais euh on
nous nous nous sommes préparer à ça
c'est c'est une réalité que nous avons
bien compris euh c'est aussi euh euh et
nous sommes pris nous sommes prêts à euh
aller dans dans dans cette dans ce
nouveau chementin pour nous euh sachant
que pour ça il il faut vraiment avoir
uneunion européenne qui est qui a fait
des réformes nécessaires pour qu'elle
puisse fonctionner et pour ça il faut
vraiment savoir quelle Union européenne
on veut pour pour le futur merci Mons
trs bien la question des ressources
propres est essentielle bien sûr sur ce
que vous dites puis il y a deux il y a
deux cas de figure il y a ceux qui
étaient contributeurs net et qui vont
devenir qui étaient bénéficiaaires net
et qui vont devenir contributeurs net
puis ceux qui étaient contributeurs net
et qui vont être encore plus
contributeurs net et et ça c'est c'est
c'est dans l'esprit dans l'esprit de nos
compatriotes un peu difficile à
comprendre et il y a beaucoup de
pédagogie à faire comme le disait
Monsieur l'Ambassadeur avec peut-être
une information au aux citoyens qui qui
est beaucoup plus importante mais
l'information au citoyens elle passe
aussi par l'information des
parlementaires et c'est très bien que il
y a eu ce soir beaucoup de sénateurs de
de notre commission qui était qui était
présent je vous propose qu'on se
retrouve désormais au salon beaufranc où
où normalement les présidents un nombre
de présidents des groupes
d'amitié de la France avec avec vos avec
vos pays sont présents dans la petite le
petit verre de l'amitié qu'on va prendre
tous
ensemble